so in some sad youtube news that
probably qualifies for its own darwin
award a man was killed while attempting
to do a youtube prank
two individuals in tennessee attempted
to prank rob an individual they
were carrying butcher knives and the
would-be victim who was not in on the
joke open fired and killed
one of the two men it's important to
know that we don't have all the facts
here but it's entirely possible that
these circumstances might give rise to
self-defense
and self-defense probably makes sense
under these circumstances in tennessee
you don't have a duty to retreat if you
are not engaged in illegal activity in a
place where you have a right to be and
you are reasonably worried of an
imminent threat of
deadly or serious harm and you think
it's reasonable to use deadly force to
fight that and here
two people brandishing butcher knives
threatening to rob you
probably meets that definition so let
that be a lesson don't do stupid things
for internet fame or clout
and subscribe or i'll see you in court